tu es un peu enrumé là ou je vois tu as
un petit mouchoir ou ah ben voors tu
peux t'en servir tu veux te moucher non
parce que tu veux pas sortir ton petit
mouchoir tu veux que je sorte ma chemise
pour que tu te mouches il est gentil
papa oui qu'est-ce qu'il fait comme
métier euh il travaille à l'usine ah
c'est bien ça bah il y a au moins une
usine qui travaille en France voyez
maman travaille aussi oui et qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait maman elle mange à la
maison qu'est-ce que tu veux faire quand
tu seras grande comme métier
maquilleuse parce que tu sais que nous
on a des maquilleuses en principe il
doit y en avoir une là tenez passez-moi
votre
accessoire voilà ça c'est la maquilleuse
qui me maquille fais voir si tu saurais
me maquiller ben ça c'est pour me
frotter dessus pour mettre de la poudre
vas-y
voà vas-y n'hésite pas hein oh c'est une
bonne maquill de télévision ça donc je
suis bien maquillé
[Applaudissements]